what's happening there reject nation
thank you so much for clicking on this
video if you can leave a like i really
appreciate it uh we are on our way to go
watch spider-man no way home but we
thought we'd rush to go into the
premiere once in a lifetime event
because we got so many social media
messages about this batman trip
and i was like well we got we got to
cover this it has new footage in it and
that's why a lot of you guys are hitting
us up and of course really looking
forward to this if there's anything
you've seen that's most hyped about it's
been three films properly spider-man no
way home matrix and batman guys we gotta
get to it let's do it
[Music]
did you say joker yeah that sounds like
what's
[Music]
oh
[Music]
i know
who are you under there
what is the price for your blind eyes
i got
you never gets old
no
god this music is amazing
[Music]
i think so i mean the voiceovers
it has to be right yeah it sounds like
you said joker at the beginning it did
sound like that we don't speak japanese
somebody translate down in the comments
yeah it sounds like he's saying joke is
it another word or is it yeah it sounds
like joker to my american hero
you just want to hear jokers it's all
you batman fans everyone here is the
next joker i gotta say man watching it
with the japanese narration even though
i don't know what he's saying a lot of
times yeah sounds badass yeah
i was like our trailer voices cannot
sometimes overdo it but i was like i
would love to have this narration almost
like an anime trailer got them by
gaslight
that's not a name batman ninja
all animation is anime now that is just
extreme confirmation that riddler knows
the identity of batman it's gonna be
interesting to watch a villain of this
caliber of knowledge taking on the
batman and psychologically tormenting
him he hasn't been trying to reach you
bruce wayne yeah it's direct already
from the first trailer the teaser it was
pretty apparent that he knew and this
just solidifies that really feels like
we're going to be uncovering the dark
secrets of the wayne family history yeah
as this story ultimately progresses and
just how much control i mean it's been
such a trope especially ever since
actually the dark knight the criminal
wanted to be caught here you know he's
captured but he's still in control of
the situation especially knowing that
batman is bruce wayne just how much he
can control that oh knowing so many
intimate details about yeah not only
bruce but the wayne family i can imagine
that that would make for a really great
source of tension throughout the movie
because it's partly like yeah he's not
going to give up all the information
because that's part of the game but also
pretty much any information he has is
going to be pretty damaging for bruce
yeah man it's going to it seems like
it's going to be investigating trying to
find the regular catches of river but
then the river wanted to get caught just
the beginning this is planned the whole
time it's like we've seen batman movies
where they know the identity of batman
but to kick off your new franchise that
way is very interesting it keeps it
grounded in the bruce wayne dichotomy
that he ultimately suffers with there's
a few like very distinct new shots that
were in this trailer you have this one
shot here that looks like edward nash's
lab or his seat his lair yeah the secret
hideout it's more than just that like he
left a clue here for bruce wayne yeah
yeah yeah he's probably gonna be finding
these question marks throughout the
movie yeah he wanted bruce to find it
yeah absolutely that's part of the the
cat and mouse trail because this looks
very zodiac like this looks very seven
yeah uh in the way this layer's all all
assembled but to have the question mark
there meaning he wanted his letter to be
found and come look at this area
particularly and then you have uh this
set of photos here on the wall just
expanding upon that a lot of it like
wayne spotted reclusive billionaire
scene with mystery woman bruce wayne at
city hall for crucial talks if only i
knew then what i know
now and i love like the carving out on
the eyeballs that he has like he's been
tracking him and trailing him like it
seems like the whole year that bruce
wayne has been batman well there's also
this little question mark target around
that kid's face and i'm sitting here
wondering is that young edward nashton
or is that young bruce wayne now i feel
like this is all bruce wayne related it
seems like yeah yeah but i wonder too if
they have some kind of connection that
we'll discover you know later on in the
movie that maybe links them as kids or
something like that they were best
friends they were best friends but
somehow he just forgot
it was like
who he would be and then of course from
the teaser trailer the moment will look
like alexander skarsgard that i'm
thinking no peter stark's got peter
peterson my favorite sleepy guy where
he's taped up and has the bomb and the
the car crashes through do you have the
shot here of bruce wayne looking up and
then up at the top
brother's been watching this whole time
i love how they've kept him concealed
and this like silhouetted messed up
shadow it's been pretty cool how they've
managed to maintain that with the
marketing even though we know who's
playing him we all know who's playing it
but they but they still put you in the
perspective even in the marketing of how
batman slash bruce wayne is perceiving
the situation yeah it's a good way to
put you into that mystery directly of
yeah bypassing the technicality of the
actor and just going who is this
character going to be revealed to be and
you know even though paul dano like i'm
sure he'll look kind of like paul dano
at the same time you know with so much
build up and so much presence just based
on his voice and the surrounding
aesthetics you know i like that they're
still building up to that it's like now
and maybe they'll show more of his face
or more of you know him and bruce
actually interacting in another trailer
but for right now i'm actually really
excited for that because yeah it's like
even though i know kind of what paul
dana looks like and what one of those
masks he has looks like it does get you
really sort of enticed by the identity
underneath it all and what the
performance is going to reveal from that
the nuances in his face and expressions
and and his you know portrayal of the
character are gonna be and i love when
especially it seems like batman movies
are apt to do this where they get you
excited not only to see a character
realized for the first time or again on
screen but they get you really excited
for the choice of actor and like what
the performance is going to be maintain
that sort of cinematic quality last
thing i'll say is every little tease
that we got right from the first look of
robert pattinson we've gotten in new
layers of michael giaccino's score this
scores it just seems like it's shaping
up to be one of his best
yeah you i feel like people bring a
special amount of juice and a game for
batman yeah yeah i like the string music
and this one in particular and the
violin yeah especially towards the end
the things and that might be some kind
of reinterpolation of under the bridge
or whatever but it sounded like there
were certain elements that were like the
stringed instruments but more like raked
and strummed in a way that they wouldn't
normally be to enhance the sort of rough
grit of everything we've been seeing
here so yeah i can't wait to hear all
that it sounds like a real film score
you know what i mean yeah it doesn't
sound like a comic book yeah that sounds
like yeah dark sevens type films
i'm very much excited for this movie man
can't wait i hope we get another
official trailer uh
january or february comes out of march
so we got to get another one right and
all the tv spots don't forget
we're going to be there
if there's a second a new footage you
know we're there man that's the new way
to market is just give us one second to
do that
we're all going to zoom in on it leave
your thoughts down below what'd you
think about this international trailer
what was your favorite part about it
subscribe click that bell hit that like
button we'll catch you guys soon